WESLEY CHUN:
Greetings, developers.
As you know, images are a
necessity in any presentation.
But if you stop to think about
it, text is also important.
Because there's less text in a
slide deck compared to images,
any text that you do
have has higher impact.
Hi, this is Wesley Chun, your
friendly neighborhood G Suite
developer advocate.
Today I'll be showing you how to
format that very important text
using the Google Slides API.
One, perhaps surprising,
thing about Google Slides
is that reading is
different from writing text.
What I mean by that is
when you read slides,
you see how the text
is formatted and stored
internally.
But when you write text, you
just provide the raw copy
and where to write it to.
Make sense?
Furthermore, writing text is
different from formatting it.
When you format text,
you need to know
something about its
internal structure
as well as styling
requests, neither of which
were really required when
you're just writing it.
In this sense, formatting
text is more like reading it.
Think of it this way.
Reading isn't going to be what
you can do the most with text
in slide decks.
Rather, you focus on
writing and formatting it.
And those are designed
to be similar operations
that you would do in the
Slides user interface.
When you enter or
write text, you're
just typing without formatting.
And that's something you
would do typically afterwards.
All right, let's see
how to do all three.
Writing text is the
most straightforward,
so we'll start with that.
To insert text, send
and insert text requests
to the presentation's
.batch update method,
providing both the raw text plus
the object to write that text
into.
In addition to text
boxes, you can write text
into any shape,
even the weird ones.
Where else can you
write text into?
Table cells.
Well, to do that, you must
provide the text like normal
but also specify
the cell location,
meaning row and column.
And whether you write into
a shape or a table cell,
the insertion index
defaults to zero,
unless you want that text
inserted into another location.
And if so, you need
to provide that index.
What else can you do with
text besides writing it?
Well, you can delete text,
perform a global search
and replace.
But you can also
update text formatting
as well as update the
bullet style for paragraphs.
Delete and search
and replace should
be fairly straightforward.
So today's video is all
about text formatting,
so we'll focus on
the latter pair.
Before we get started
with formatting,
you need to know something
about the structure of text
in a presentation.
While writing text doesn't
expose you to this,
reading will.
If you read a slide
using presentations.get
a peek at your
slides will reveal
something that may look
like this for a text box.
The text elements include
both a paragraph marker,
like bullet glyphs and
alignment, as well as
the actual text copy
and current styling.
Formatting text involves using
the update tech style request,
where you pass in the ID
of the shape containing
the affected text, the
styling changes to make,
which range of text
should be updated,
and which field should be
affected by this request.
Adding bullets is similar,
using the createParagraphBullets
request.
We'll take a look at both
request types in our code
sample.
Now, be sure to have the latest
client library installed,
whether it's in Python or
in your favorite language.
Also make sure to have created
a project in the dev console
with the Slides API enabled.
We recommend you also review
the text structure and styling
concept guide for background
before proceeding.
If you're all set,
let's go to the computer
and look at some
formatting code.
We'll start with
lines 1 through 13,
which are your standard imports
and boilerplate authorization
code, except for what we
need for this application,
meaning the read-write
scope for slides on line 7
and creation of the service
endpoint on line 13.
Lines 15 to 21 is where we
create a brand new slide
deck with presentations.create.
From the API response, grab
the presentation ID along
with the IDs for the
title and subtitle,
text boxes on the front page.
Most commands are
sent to the API
by calling
presentations.batchupdate.
And lines 23 to 31 are where
we build and send the requests
to create a new slide
with the main point layout
and also add the main
title and subtitle text.
Since createSlide was the
first command in the array,
grab the new slide ID
at index 0 on line 31,
ignoring the responses for
the insert text commands.
Main point layout slides
have one giant text box.
And on lines 33 to 36 we
use presentations.pages.get
to fetch that ID.
This is the command
that you'd use to get
all the objects on any slide.
And since there's only one thing
on this slide, the text box,
grab it at index 0 on line 36.
Lines 38 to 44 is where
we start putting together
the text formatting commands,
starting with inserting six
paragraphs into the text box.
The main point text box
default font size is 48.
And on lines 45 to 51,
we shrink it down to 32.
A text range of all means to
shrink the entire text box.
In future requests, we'll use
more specific text ranges,
starting with bolding
the first word
in the first paragraph
which is at index 0
through 3 on lines 52 to 58.
Note, the end index is excluded.
That's why it's 4.
Bolding is done by
setting its style
and using fields to only affect
the bold style and nothing
else, meaning leave the font
color, type, and size alone.
Lines 59 to 65 is identical
to the bold request
but italicize the first word in
the second paragraph instead,
which is at indexes 7 to 10.
66 to 72 is where we
change the first word
in the last paragraph to a
mono-spaced font, specifically
Courier New.
Lines 73 to 77 add bullets
to begin all paragraphs
in the entire text range.
The last few lines just
send the commands to the API
and lets the user know
that everything's done.
Let's run it and
see what we get.
We'll see the output as
the API requests are made.
And then we're going to
confirm, after it's done,
that the new slide deck
was created-- ta-da.
You see it appear here
in the Drive folder,
where we'll open it up.
There's the title slide.
And boom, here's our fancy
formatted second slide.
Wasn't that awesome?
Now you know how to read,
write, and format text
in Google Slides presentations.
All it takes is knowing
the right request
to send to the API,
like the text formatting
ones you see here.
Where can you go now?
Well, if you're brand
new to the Slides API,
check out the overview
introducing you to the concepts
you need to know.
One of the keys to
successfully using the API
is to understand its requests.
The common operations
and API samples
docs pages are a great resource
to gaining this knowledge.
And if you want to dive straight
into the reference docs,
the last link will
take you there.
Now, we can all agree that
presentations are generally
focused on imparting
ideas through images.
Since there's less
text, any that you do
have must be more meaningful.
Well, thanks for joining us
into this intro to text format
and with Google Slides API.
Now you can format that
all-important text,
increasing its impact
in your presentations.
Be sure to subscribe
to our channel and tune
in again next time.
This is Wesley Chun from Google.
And we'll see you
around in the G Suite.
Hey, everyone.
Thanks for watching.
Check out these related videos.
And we'll see you next time.